Carlos Seville is the sweet acrobatic
son of the notorious Disney villain
Cruella Deville from 101 Dalmatians in
The Descendants movies Carlos mal Evie
and de try to leave their evil roots
behind to join the fairytale kids at
Aragon prep watch until the end to find
out about Carlos's tragic past and why
he always felt different than the other
bk's you guys have it pretty rough on
the island
Carlos is full name it's Carlos Oscar
Deville he is the descendant of the
puppy crazed villain karela Deville when
we meet him in the first movie it's
clear that he has had a rough childhood
but he was actually first introduced in
the book I love the lost a descendents
novel in the book Carlos was bullied by
none other than Jay and mal he has a
cousin named Diego who is thought to be
the son of karelas brother Cecil B
Deville he made an appearance on the 101
dalmatians TV show we know that Carlos
was raised to think that dogs are
ferocious beasts which caused him to
have an embarrassing fear of even the
smallest of canines luckily he overcame
that fear and even befriended dude the
dog in descendants - but let's go back a
bit and find out more about the
background of this son of a puppy thief
in order to do that we should probably
go back to before he even came into the
picture let's take a look at his mom
Cruella Deville
do you remember the song from Disney's
101 Dalmatians with the lyrics but just
how did Cruella wind up with that curl
in her lip and that ice in her stare if
you put the two parts of her last name
together it spells devil but surely she
wasn't always mean and sinister right
well apparently she was always evil even
as a baby in the Christmas episode of
101 Dalmatians the TV series karelas
parents had left her with a babysitter
over the holidays they sent her a
Christmas present signed
mr. and mrs. de Vil instead of mom and
dad clearly they weren't very close to
their child
anyway Cruella is really hoping for a
puppy but when she opens her gift it's
just a polyester outfit let's just say
karela did not take this very well she
threw a huge temper tantrum then she had
her babysitter shipped away in a box
proving she's always had an evil
streak in the show the ghost of
Christmas past psycho analyzes Cruella
the spirit puppy said it's obvious that
her yearning for a puppy when she was a
child
represented something deeper the spirit
pup said it represented a deep-seated
need to substitute the love she didn't
get from her parents with the dog
so if karela was never taught how to
love by her own parents how could she
possibly be able to properly show love
to her own son Carlos here's what we
know about the relationship Carlos has
with his mother in the first dissidence
movie it seems like Cruella was really
going to miss Carlos when he left to go
to auradon that isn't how we see that
the real reason she wants him around is
so he can touch up her roots fluff her
fur in I love the loss we get a glimpse
at just how tough it was for Carlos
growing up he is forced to sleep in his
mother's dressing room which was bear
traps scattered throughout to protect
her first this may have contributed to
Carlos's acrobatic skills and cleverness
since yet to find alternative ways to
enter the room so he could sleep carlos
was forced by his mother to look after
and clean her furs Pirela made it
abundantly clear that she loves her furs
more than she loves Carlos but we're
pretty sure she doesn't love him at all
what kind of mother refers to her car as
her baby but not her own child it's no
wonder he developed quirky little
survival skills like reciting the
periodic table to himself when he gets
nervous so how did Carrillo maintain
such a tight grasp of control of her
Carlos how did she get him to provide
her with free slave labor all those
years well this is the super evil part
karela instilled a huge fear of dogs
into young Carlos's mind she used this
fear to control him she told him that
dogs are rabid pack animals who eat boys
who don't behave so Carlos did all this
fur fluffing root touch-ups and callous
scraping because he was afraid he
thought if he didn't do all those things
a pack of vicious dogs would come and
eat him not a cool karela it seems that
Karelas control extended over the waters
following Carlos all the way to Oregon
prep in the opening number of
descendants to Carlos sings that he can
still hear his mother's voice in his
head so how did Carlos cope well Carlos
was given a cat named Beelzebub when he
was little a TV sixth birthday party
Carlos received one of Lucifer's kitten
you remember Lucifer lady Jermaine's
evil cat from Cinderella all right what
did you do with this little kitten
helped Carlos get through many troubling
times just like his mother when she was
little Carlos had to look to a pet in
order to get the affection that was
missing from his parents or figures when
he was growing up we're not sure what
happened to Beelzebub we don't see the
cat in The Descendants movies maybe
Cruella fed it to some rabid dogs to
teach Carlos a lesson sounds like
something she would do poor Carlos and
speaking of parental figures who is
Carlos his dad he hasn't been brought up
in the films at all it seems like single
parenthood is a consistent thread among
the villains on the Isle it must be
pretty hard to maintain a healthy
relationship with all the evil plotting
and scheming they do there must not be
much time for anything else plus there's
a good chance that they wouldn't make
the best partners being that every one
of them is pretty self-centered still it
takes two to produce a villain offspring
that's just how biology and procreation
works so who is Carlos's father one fan
has a theory about who Carlos's dad
could be she points out that karela
isn't exactly dripping with hot dates in
fact the only man she's usually seen
with are her henchman Jasper and Horace
according to one fan it's probably
Jasper since he has a thin build like
Carlos but another fan theory is even
wackier this dissonance theory blogger
breaks it down for us apparently Cruella
had forbidden Carlos to ever ask about
his father even though he was very
curious and would have loved to know
more about him so who is this mystery
man since Carlos was conceived on the
Isle it's safe to assume that his dad
must be some other Disney villain and
since there is no mention of him he
could either be deceased escaped or
locked in karelas dressing room for
displeasing her but if that last one
were true Carlos would have surely run
into him so we don't have a lot to go on
however let's look at Carlos to get some
clues Carlos his skin tone is lighter
than his mom's so his father must have
lighter skin
Carlos is also pretty tech savvy he made
a machine that once broke the barrier of
the aisle he was able to break down the
alarm system of the Museum of cultural
history to
false alarm so maybe his father is some
sort of tech genius so if he is a Disney
villain no could he be the dissonance
theory blogger did a quick rundown on
Carlos's attributes to narrow it down
the blogger pointed out that Carlos's
dad must be a Disney villain who is
white and has freckles he also must be
good at technology and he's most likely
deceased or otherwise unavailable here's
the crazy part this blogger narrowed it
down to one wackadoo villain who goes by
the name of King candy Carlos is sort of
obsessed with chocolate and in return to
the Isle of the Lost
Carlos says he learned how to drive so
he could chauffeur his mother around
even though karela could have just asked
one of her henchmen to do so this fan
thinks that's a hint from karela since
King candy is a racecar driver from two
video games it makes sense that Carlos
would be a good driver King candy also
understands how to recode the game sugar
rush in order to put himself in charge
so there's the tech-savvy part of the
equation but can a video game character
hook up with a fur wearing lunatic who
knows all we know is that it's pretty
heartbreaking that Carlos grew up
without ever knowing who his father is
he wasn't even allowed to ask any
questions about his dad he's had to rely
on his friends and his pets for love and
companionship
then there's the bullying I was gonna
say that sure mal Evie and Jay are good
friends with Carlos now but it wasn't
always that way we know from the books
at mal and Jay bullied Carlos one time
in the Isle of the Lost
mal forces Carlos to throw a party at
Carla's house so she could mess with
Evie then mal pranks Evie locking her in
karelas closet Carlos helped Evie escape
from the dressing room making her his
first human friend
for this reason Carlos stand out against
the other DK's because well he showed EB
mercy in her time of need Carlos doesn't
become friends with mal and Jay and how
Evie convinces him to join their quest
to restore the magic in Maleficent staff
but it seems that Jay still picks on
Carlos a lot so Carlos who is the
youngest in the VK gang has been abused
and enslaved by his mother and on top of
that he is bullied by the other kids
it's a pretty rotten childhood how did
he turn out to be so nice after all of
that well we think that his friendship
and his companion dude the dog helped a
lot there's a great scene in the first
descendants movie when Carlos stands up
to his mother the villain kids are in a
video chat set up by the fairy godmother
so they can talk to their parents on
family day at auradon prep the villains
are doing their best to appear sweet and
pretend that they really care about
their kids
but the BJ's can see right through them
they know that all they care about is
getting fairy godmothers magic wand the
kids are away from their parents so for
the first time the parents don't have
control over them
Carlos stands in front of the video chat
screen holding dude the dog karela jumps
up and yells at Carlos asking him if he
actually is holding a dog then she
creepily talks to the stuffed dog on her
shoulder saying she thinks dude the dog
would make the perfect size for earmuffs
then Carlos stands up to her saying that
his dog is the perfect size for a pet he
proclaims his love for the dog and says
dude loves him too
Vinnie reminds her that while he has a
living and very loving dog his mom's dog
is stuffed then he yells at her well
done Carlos someone's got to stand up to
that horrible woman his outburst
really shocked Cruella because well it
proved that he'd no longer believed in
her brainwashing tactics
despite his heartbreaking backstory
Carlos is still a pretty lovable
character he's got mad acrobatic skills
he can juggle
he's a total tech whiz a loyal friends
and a pretty sweet boyfriend to Jane
Carlos overcame his fear of dogs even
though he was brainwashed into thinking
they were vicious animals I could
possibly eat him this proves that he can
think for himself and make his own
decisions he is brave adventurous caring
and funny and even though Carlos was
bullied by the villain kids at first he
was able to turn them into valuable
allies and true friends this goes to
show that even a person that has been
treated badly in the past they can turn
it around and create their own future
one fan revealed that they appreciated
Carlos's character so much more after
they learned about his backstory the fan
said his life was absolutely
heartbreaking they also added that
Carlos is so much more than just the son
of a villain and that he truly is a good
boy so what part of Carlos his backstory
was the most heartbreaking to you hit us
up in the comments and let us know what
makes Carlos so special give this video
a big thumbs up if you think Carlos is
the greatest before you go don't forget
to subscribe to the bangs and while
you're at it hit that notification bell
to be the first to see our latest videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]